welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is Eric Trexler I am the
special temporary primary host of the
show today I am joined by Greg Knuckles
he is currently the permanent guest
co-host for the time being and you
probably recognize him because he's been
on many many episodes in the past uh
before we get into today's content as
always if you like the show and you'd
like to support it there are many ways
you could do that you could like rate or
subscribe wherever you get your podcasts
you could go to strongerbyscience.com
newsletter and join our mailing list we
send out a bunch of updates about new
exciting research pertaining to exercise
and nutrition uh you if you're looking
for a coach for one-on-one virtual
coaching we do offer that if you go to
strongerbyscience.com coaching you can
get more information about our pricing
our services and our very talented team
of coaches
if you want to get cheap supplements or
inexpensive supplements I should say but
you want to get them even less
expensively you can go to
bulksupplements.com and use our discount
code that is SBS pod it gets you a five
percent discount off of your order and
their prices are already very very
reasonable and then finally if you'd
like to support the show you could
subscribe to the mass research review
which comes out the first of the month
every single month covering the newest
most useful research pertaining to
exercise and nutrition or you could
check out macro Factor that's the diet
app that we co-developed uh it's a very
very efficient Food Locker food logger
it has automated coaching functions very
very nice Diet app and there is a free
trial so you can try it out and see if
you like it before you make a financial
commitment
uh so diving in uh I'm doing well Eric
thanks for having me on how are you I'm
doing great I I assumed you were doing
well usually when someone gets an
opportunity to come onto a podcast like
this they're over the moon they're very
excited and thrilled at the chance so I
assume that you were in a great a great
mood and really happy and just kind of
feeling very fortunate and grateful to
be here I am a creature of habit and I
just felt like we needed to get that out
there before I felt we were ready to
dive in okay well now that we're both on
board and ready to move forward uh two
things we want to do before we get into
the science segments here uh the first
thing is
a while ago I published an article about
reverse dieting it was uh published on
on the macro Factor website macro
factorapp.com and I looked at reverse
dieting from a very critical perspective
I just looked at the evidence and said
okay of all the claims that are floating
around about reverse dieting what seems
to be supported by evidence and what
seems to be unsupported and even going a
step further what seems to be directly
contradicted by the best evidence we
have available so that was published I
guess a couple weeks ago or a few weeks
ago I'll link it in the show notes if
you haven't seen it it's very long just
as a warning but since we published that
article and did a podcast segment about
it I have gotten some feedback that I
wanted to respond to and I also wanted
to make a pretty important clarification
because a number of questions have come
up in the last couple weeks so first of
all talking about some of the kind of
criticism or feedback I've gotten most
of the feedback's been been quite
positive which has been very appreciated
and of course I I appreciate uh critical
feedback as well as long as it's
substantive and and very you know to the
point
uh I wanted to respond to a couple
things I've seen uh in some of the
feedback so first of all some people
have said that I was
um a little bit too skeptical about
reverse dieting uh and and basically
they said hey
absence of evidence is not the same
thing as evidence of absence and so what
they were getting at there is just
because you know there's no definitive
proof in the evidence of reverse dieting
working as claimed that doesn't mean
that it necessarily cannot work
um and so that's a true statement
absence of evidence is not the same as
evidence of absence or evidence of no
effect at all
um however
it's difficult to make that argument and
and say you know hey you know we should
look the other way with this reverse
dieting stuff because there are
literally books and courses about quote
unquote evidence-based reverse dieting
right so one of my claims that is kind
of central to the argument is you know
whether you want to do reverse dieting
or not it's very very very difficult to
make the argument that this is an
evidence-based approach or an
evidence-based strategy
um I also would argue against the
perspective
that we have a true absence of evidence
here um you know I found 60 pages of
stuff to write about that there is uh
evidence that is indirect but is still
highly relevant to the claims that are
being made about reverse dieting so I
think that it is incorrect to say hey we
know absolutely nothing at all about
reverse dieting or the relevant claims
about it and therefore it would be
inappropriate to have any opinion
whatsoever about it about its
Effectiveness or efficacy there there is
evidence to draw upon and frankly uh it
all looks pretty bad for a lot of the
reverse dieting claims that are out
there yeah I think the I think just that
phrase absence of evidence is an
Evidence of absence I I think that
that's one of those
one of those little things that is
technically true but uh can be uh a
somewhat dangerous idea to get lodged in
someone's head if they don't have a
requisite amount of just like scientific
literacy going into it sort of the same
thing as correlation isn't causation
because like those aren't the actual
statements it's absence of evidence
isn't necessarily evidence of absence
and correlation doesn't necessarily
imply causation
um but like for for absence of evidences
and evidence of absence like there's
I think some people try to use that as
like a get out of jail free card if
their pet idea hasn't been validated but
absence of evidence like I said the the
statement should be isn't necessarily
evidence of absence but it can be so uh
like a scenario where uh it it wouldn't
be evidence of absence like the classic
example is there are no rcts on the
efficacy of parachutes to prevent fall
deaths When jumping out of a plane uh
you know there there is an absence of
rcts on that but you know I don't think
anyone would argue that that absence of
evidence is evidence of absence like
parachutes clearly work but uh imagine
an alternate world where there were 30
rcts on the efficacy of wearing a
parachute when you jump out of a plane
for for preventing fall deaths and let's
just say in this world parachutes don't
work so you've run those rcts and in
every single one the people without
parachutes and the people with
parachutes all die at the same rates
you could still say well that that's
absence of evidence like you haven't
conclusively proved like you know when
you're doing null hypothesis testing
like you don't you don't prove the null
you just fail to disprove it so you
could you could say like we have an
absence of evidence that parachutes work
but like I'm Gonna Keep claiming they do
but that's like in this scenario you're
getting further down the road where this
thing has been studied enough that the
absence of evidence can start being
taken as evidence of absence and I I
think that with reverse dieting it's
more like that scenario like there have
been enough studies where if reverse
dieting did what it is claimed to do uh
that would have shown up in in the
research by now so like it's it's at the
point where the absence of evidence is
starting to look like evidence of
absence yeah yeah and and I it kind of
reminds me of our our back and forth
about P ratios where like no one uh to
mind all I can't think of a study off
the top of my head where someone said
we're going to do an RCT and address
this head-on and and once and for all
solve this very specific question right
but it's along the same lines where
we're like so if this is true uh there's
a lot of resistance training research
and there are many areas in which this
should be starting to this effect if
real and meaningful should be starting
to reveal itself to us in some of these
related and indirect studies right we
should be getting glimpses of it hints
of it and we're looking at the evidence
saying we're getting in some cases no
hints of it and in some cases the
literal opposite you know it appeared to
be contradicted by the evidence
available yeah and I think with reverse
dieting I mean if you're going to make
the argument that we simply don't know
much about how weight loss works or how
weight regain works I mean it's one of
the more studied Topics in the realm of
Public Health there there is evidence to
be dug through uh and and like I said it
all roads are pointing to a pretty uh
pretty dissatisfying outcome for reverse
dieting
uh the other piece of of criticism I
want to briefly respond to uh is you
know well in in figures 10 and 11 you
kind of made the assumption that someone
was starting from a deficit when they
begin their reverse diet they start
building up calories from a deficit at
the end of the diet and some people say
well I go to estimated maintenance
calories and then I reverse diet from
there
um and I think some people made that
claim with and I'm not saying this to be
a smart ass I don't think they read the
article because that is not a
substantive rebuttal to really any
primary claim within the article and so
if I was going to take that criticism
and restructure the article entirely to
accommodate this use case I'm pretty
sure I would achieve that a hundred
percent if I just change the axis labels
on figure 10 and figure 11. so some
people kind of lobbed that out as a like
a gotcha like ah well what if you did
this and I'm like well then based on
almost all the text I just gave you it
still wouldn't do anything yeah you know
so that those are the two pieces of
feedback that I received as criticism
and I was like I I I think it's valuable
to get criticism for your work but it
has to be more substantive than that
like you gotta actually engage with the
topics a little deeper
um so overall
most of the feedback's been positive
um when I look at the user level
pushback so people who are not Fitness
professionals they don't make Fitness
content but they're just like hey you
know I tried reverse Diagon dieting and
I thought it actually worked better than
you're representing here
um so far a hundred percent of those
when they describe their experience I
can just kind of Point them to Illusions
one through four one of them will apply
to their situation so so far that's been
the case where I just say yeah that
sounds a lot like illusion number three
that's kind of the end of it
um in terms of professional level
pushback again I've just kind of been uh
a little bit underwhelmed in the sense
that the critical feedback has lacked a
lot of substance it hasn't really said
oh you made some evidence-based claims
with research I'm going to look at other
research and you know have a rebuttal
with a different perspective on the
evidence it's usually just a lot of like
deflection or like well I don't know
here's like a vague state statements
statement about evidence of absence or
something so yeah that's been um just
really underwhelming and if anyone does
happen to to put together a substantive
rebuttal to any of the points you know
obviously I'd be happy to address that
and and Converse with those individuals
but so far it just hasn't really
happened
um and yeah they just to me
I don't know that's been a slightly
frustrating I don't want to bring the
mood down here and and be uh pedantic
and annoying but it is a little bit
frustrating when when there are
literally people who all of their
marketing is about how evidence-based
they are and all of their social media
content is very self-congratulatory oh
I'm so evidence-based and then it's like
once you present some evidence for for a
pet Theory they're like they're just
allergic to engaging with evidence like
I'm I'm not going to read it I'm not
going to respond to it in a substantive
way and I'm certainly not going to look
for evidence to actually support this
concept to me that's a little bit uh a
little bit disappointing so uh that is
all the feedback responses I have but I
do want to make an important
clarification because I did get a number
of questions from people
um
that we're all kind of in the same
general genre
and it's because I I definitely
presented an idea without fully
clarifying uh what I was getting at you
know so I definitely take the L on that
one I should have explained this with a
lot more clarity
um so I talked a little bit about
preferential fat regain after weight
loss and so a lot of people have said
okay well if that's the case like
are you just totally screwed if you do a
cut and eventually want to bulk in the
future you know so if you're trying to
bulk from a body weight or a body fat
level that is lower than your previous
maximum does that mean that you're just
going to fail and all the weight you
gain is going to be fat rather than lean
mass and a related question is people
say well does this mean I need to do a
prolonged maintenance phase after a cut
before I'm able to bulk again
successfully
um and again I just failed to explain
that point adequately but uh I don't
think that someone is just like totally
screwed like I I don't think that
bulking is off the table effective
bulking if you're at a reduced body
weight
um and I don't think you need to do a
maintenance phase necessary you can but
you don't need to do a maintenance phase
between a cut and the next bulk so
definitely preferential fat regain after
a weight loss diet has been documented
in past research
um and that's important that that gives
us valuable information about how a
wheat reduced body responds to over
feeding usually uh you know pretty um
pretty rapid over feeding or high
amounts of overfeeding but a lot of that
research basically all of it is from
people
samples of people who were not lifting
weights and therefore had no stimulus
for muscle growth or it's in physique
athletes who are very well trained in
terms of their their degree of
hypertrophy and their degree of
muscularity and they're also extremely
lean like getting to near essential body
fat levels you know as lean as a person
would hope to get without serious
adverse Health consequences so
that that propensity for fat regain is
important to recognize but that you know
we have to remember that the the uh
success of a bulking phase is going to
be dictated uh very heavily by whether
or not you have a sufficient uh stimulus
for substantial hypertrophy right and
then whether or not you have created
conditions that are permissive of
hypertrophy so when we talk about you
know a really you know really muscular
physique athlete who is absolutely
shredded their post diet experience and
that immediate post Diet phase it's
unlikely that they're going to be doing
a lot of hypertrophy because they're
probably
somewhat close to their genetic limit in
some cases you know so they don't they
don't have kilograms of muscle tissue to
add in a short period of time or
something that is is more commonly true
not not every bodybuilder is like at
their genetic limit right but if you're
getting down to contest shape you're
probably not at a body fat level where
precipitous hypertrophy is going to be
feasible you know a lot of times we get
down to that unique physiological state
where we are absolutely shredded and
even an RP ratio uh investigation with
some of the analysis we did people that
are in single digit body fat uh males
with single-digit body fat it's very
challenging for them to gain
significance amount of lean mass in the
absence of a fat Mass gain right and so
so the conditions for hypertrophy are
not very suitable for the physique
athlete in that situation and like I
said for someone who's not lifting
weights the post diet weight regain uh
you know it's it's that propensity
exists but we also have to factor in the
fact that there is is no potent stimulus
for muscle hypertrophy there so in terms
of practically speaking what this means
is
if you're someone who's not near a
genetic limit you're not absolutely
shredded at the end of a diet uh and
you're you're implementing a sufficient
training static uh training stimulus
that would elicit a significant amount
of hypertrophy
the idea of doing a bulk without
substantial fat regain should still be
very feasible for you you know you are
in a set of conditions that is
permissive for successful bulking
without a ton of fat gain but in the
post diet window this is really what I'm
getting at with this argument
in the postdiet window as you're
transitioning into that bulking phase
and you'd like to avoid fat regain what
I argue is that there's slightly less
margin for error in terms of how high
you go with your calories right so if
you are doing this bulking phase and you
are doing a really good job of matching
your caloric intake to the actual true
energy cost of the hypertrophy that
you're stimulating you know so you're
not way overshooting it if you're able
to match that up really well I see no
reason why you shouldn't be able to have
a really successful bulking phase after
a cut where you're not inviting you know
precipitous fat gain in the process but
the question is when you go over what
happens right and so when we look at the
overfeeding literature we can see that
when people are over feeding from a kind
of typical natural body weight
for a lot of people there's a little bit
of a cushion there where total daily
energy expenditure will ramp up
adaptively to kind of offset over
feeding and that it differs a lot from
person to person some people don't have
much capacity for that but at a neutral
body weight
for a lot of people if they if they're
bulking from a natural body weight and
they overshoot a little bit they might
offset some of that overshooting with
their calories by by some adjustments in
energy expenditure but but what I argue
is based on the the over or the uh the
preferential fat regain that we observe
in these studies it's exceedingly
unlikely that you're going to have that
same uh buffer that same margin of error
after a weight loss diet so so what I'm
arguing here is you absolutely can go
straight from a cut into a successful
lean bulking phase but the margin for
error is a little bit tighter after you
know when you're bulking in a weight
reduced state so you probably want to
take it a little bit slower you want to
make sure you have a really robust
stimulus for hypertrophy in the mix make
sure you have a you know a really
effective training program in place you
want to take that cut slower a little
bit more conservative smaller increase
in calories so that you're really
effectively matching the true energy
cost of of that muscle building process
with the energy that you're taking in
because if you overshoot it that's where
we see that this preferential fat regain
seems to be a little bit more of a
pertinent issue yeah I mean it makes
sense I I think just one one thing to
add just kind of
uh conceptually is is one of the things
we've talked about on the podcast before
is recomping now
uh at least until fairly recently it
seemed like a lot of folks just kind of
assumed that that was either a myth or
like basically impossible out of outside
of just completely untrained folks
um but yeah no there's there's evidence
that like even people with some prior
training experience can still gain
muscle in a calorie deficit so just kind
of extending that uh like of course you
can gain muscle if you
are kind of at the end of a calorie
deficit and add more calories into the
mix like there I I don't see a reason to
assume that that should be impossible uh
outside of those pretty extreme
circumstances you talked about like for
example a physique competitor who's just
super shredded and their body just
really wants to regain fat because it's
not healthy to be that lean right yeah
and I think this is kind of a glaring
example of one of the biggest conceptual
issues I have with reverse dieting which
is that uh if you ever read someone's
content promoting it you know if it's if
it's you know an article the first
section or if it's a book the first
chapter often says hey when you diet
metabolic adaptation happens all these
physiological changes happen uh the post
diet period is a very very unique
physiological state that has to be
approached strategically
and then when they get to the chapter
where they say reverse dieting Works
they're basing it entirely on over
feeding studies and people who are not
in that physiological state so like the
entire setup for the problem the entire
premise they say this is a very unique
state that has to be navigated very
strategically and then literally the
evidence they're using is like so let's
assume that this isn't a unique
physiological State yeah yeah why
that's a good question all right not a
question for you I'm not going to hold
your your feet to the fire uh one other
thing I wanted to mention you I I saw
this on your uh Twitter I think uh a
incredible feat of strength uh you
should be the one to present this since
you found it uh yeah sure so uh Jamal
Browner uh who is a 110 kilo or 242
pound uh competitor in powerlifting uh
recently pulled 500 kilos in training
that is 1102 pounds for Americans
listening
um with straps but it does seem like
he's uh he's worked a lot of his grip
issues out so previously like I think uh
back when back when the Feats of
Strength segment was a more uh back when
it was in every episode type deal uh and
Jamal Browner was just really putting up
crazy numbers in the gym uh pretty
frequently he would pull something just
ridiculous with with straps but then I
think at the time his best competition
poll was still like 8 48 or something
which is still a ridiculous deadlift but
he was pulling close to a thousand with
straps seemed like he had grip issues
with really Max weights
um seems like he's really figured out
his hook grip like I I think he pulled
north of a thousand in a competition
recently
um
so yeah I mean even with straps like
over 1100 pounds is absolutely wild and
if it if his grip issues are truly
sorted out I mean seeing a 500 kilo
deadlift uh at 110 in a competition at
some point would just be absolutely wild
yeah uh but yeah you should check out
the video uh very solid pull clean
lockout uh one of the more impressive
lifts I've seen in my entire life do you
ever get over as someone who's been you
know you've had your ear to the ground
with power lifting for a long time now
does it ever get less crazy to see the
numbers people are lifting now no it
doesn't make any sense to me no I
remember I I know I've said this before
but like in 2012 I squatted 500 out of
meat uh weighing in the 170s
and I felt like a literal God like it
was like
one of the lifts at the meat that was
like wow that's a that's a pretty
impressive lift yeah and dude like no
one would be remotely impressed by that
these days like it's just crazy to see
the way that the numbers have moved I
mean
back in the day if like regardless of
body weight if you could squat like 600
pounds people were like holy [ __ ] that
person's incredibly strong yeah and now
they're they're a handful of people
doing that at like 183. I know which is
just just absolutely wild yeah
um all right so I think we're we're
clear to dive into the content uh and
your segment is up first so what do you
got for us
yeah so uh I am talking about the extent
to which uh gains in in muscle mass and
strength differ between individuals and
just uh Fitness in general increases in
Fitness level I'm going to talk about uh
variability in gains and aerobic fitness
as well
um but yeah like I wanted to talk about
this because
I think people
often severely underestimate uh the
extent to which just gains in muscle
strength general fitness levels
following a training program differ
between people
um
and I think that there are some negative
outcomes of that one is I think that uh
folks who maybe respond to training
worse than average uh but not to any
sort of like concerning or or crazy
degree you know like they're they're
they maybe have like a 30th percentile
uh type response to resistance training
which is a completely normal response uh
they look at say averages or people
showing up on their social media feed
who typically are going to be above
average that's why folks find them
interesting and therefore the algorithm
is promoting them to you and they think
oh no like I'm doing something terribly
wrong
um and you know what I'm experiencing is
very atypical but it's not like 30th
percentile like that's
that's not out of the ordinary at all
um so yeah like to hopefully give some
of those folks peace of mind and also
just to uh kind of help people get
grounded uh for for being able to better
evaluate things they see in their own
training uh gains their training
Partners make uh stuff they see on
social media Etc so just just basically
to to put people on firmer footing to
better understand the sorts of
variability you should expect to see in
training responses uh and then also
towards the end of this segment I'm
going to talk about if you are someone
who responds to training worse than the
typical person like you know I would
anticipate that this probably applies to
about 50 of folks in the audience give
or take
um some some things that you can
potentially do about that to uh either
make better gains or to maybe find a bit
more contentment in the gains that you
do see cool yeah so um
first off to start with the thing that
the the thing that kind of got me
thinking that I should make this segment
is in the stronger by science subreddit
uh when we were on summer break uh there
was a thread someone posted that that
was basically asking about this General
topic
um saying that they had gone back
through the podcast archives and they uh
had seen some content around uh around
this General subject floating around in
The Ether and they were like ah but it's
a shame Greg and Eric have never
discussed this in depth uh but I had
um so there's an article on Stronger by
science that was published I think in
2015 2016 on this precise subject uh but
that was before the podcast existed and
at this point more people listen to the
podcast than than read articles on the
site which is totally fine uh so it
hadn't occurred to me that a pretty good
chunk of our audience probably hadn't
come in contact with this information so
part of this segment is just going to be
restating some of of the content from
that article but it will take it a step
further and a step deeper but the the
stronger by science article on this
topic will be linked in the show notes
so just to start with just to give you
uh a general idea of the extent to which
uh hypertrophy following a resistance
training program can differ between
people I'm going to start by just
briefly talking about a study by Bauman
and colleagues from 2007 uh in all of
the sources that I reference will be
linked in the show notes if you want to
check them out title of this paper was
cluster analysis tests the importance of
myogenic gene expression during myofiber
hypertrophy in humans so in this study
there were 66 subjects they all went
through a 16-week training program
training their quads three times per
week
um and afterwards the authors or the the
researchers did a cluster analysis where
they basically looked to see uh like the
the split out the people who basically
had like 25th to 75th percentile type
gains the people in the bottom uh
quartile and the people in the top
quartile looking at uh gains in fiber
cross-sectional area just to see how you
know results differed between
individuals and so in this study after
everyone went through the exact same
training program for 16 weeks uh the
bottom quartile of responses on average
these people their their quad fibers did
not increase in cross-sectional area uh
at all on average like the the mean
change was Zero Square micrometers uh
for the uh who they termed modest
responders kind of the the middle 50th
percentile so from 25th to 75th
percentile uh the average increase in
fiber cross-sectional area for the
vastus lateralis was like a thousand
square micrometers and for who they
termed the extreme responders who I
really wouldn't call Extreme responders
we're talking about people from the 75th
to 100th percentile so 75th percentile
that's that's nothing extreme
um but yeah who they termed the extreme
responders the increase in fiber
cross-sectional area was a little bit
over 2 000 Square micrometers so just
going from essentially the median to
kind of what the top 20 25 percentiles
see that's like a two-fold difference in
gains uh and the person who experienced
the most uh hypertrophy in this study uh
it was like 32 3300 Square micrometers
so there the gains that that individual
saw were like three three and a half
times better than average so that's you
know just to just to kind of get your
feet wet on the the sort of variability
we tend to see and if you're if you're
watching on YouTube uh you can look at
the screen uh a figure from the study
will be there looking for or looking at
you this is really convenient the way
that the numbers uh kind of cluster
around numbers because it's like the the
lower level numbers cluster around
numbers well yeah that was a eloquent
way of saying it but let me uh try to
explain that more so like the the
approximate average for the lower
Response Group was like zero yeah and
then there were nice round numbers so
like the middle responder groups it was
like a thousand so it's like zero
hypertrophy units or one and then up
around 2 000 you know a nice doubling is
where you get the kind of high response
groups and then up around 3 000 like a
tripling of the average approximately
yeah is where you get the like basically
like the the real outlier right like the
the person that you see on Instagram and
you're like there's no way they're Natty
right well and I mean I would even push
back against that because this study had
16 subjects like yeah that's not the
sort of sample you'd need to find true
outliers well yeah yeah like that within
this sample yeah that's someone with
like one out of 60 6 type response not
one in a million yeah you know yeah uh
so yeah another I think probably even
better study that looked at this uh
classic paper by hubel and colleagues
from 2005 title is variability and
muscle size and strength gain after
unilateral resistance training the
reason this is a particularly good uh
study is because it is a particularly
huge study so it was 585 subjects all
going through the same biceps training
intervention over three months and again
if you're watching on YouTube you can
see the hypertrophy results now the the
typical change in biceps cross-sectional
area was like 15 20 percent for both the
male and female subjects but the people
who had the worst response to the
training uh actually experienced a small
decrease in biceps cross-sectional area
and these were completely untrained
folks so you know you should expect MO
most people to experience at least some
hypertrophy but the people with the very
very worst responses actually saw small
decreases and then the people with the
very very best responses experienced
increases in biceps cross-sectional area
in excess of 55 percent so you know
we're talking about untrained folks
going to the gym for the first time
training for three months and their
biceps getting 50 percent larger
um and as you pointed out with the prior
study like the best response was about
three times the average response and
that's more or less what we see here
like the average response was gains of
15 20 the best responses were like 50 60
so about three times better than average
uh and then also the study assessed
changes in maximum voluntary contraction
strength of the biceps or just elbow
flexion mvcs and you see a pretty normal
distribution here as well with most
people experiencing gains in elbow
flexion strength of around 20 percent so
so that was approximately the average
with a handful of people experiencing
small decreases a handful of people
experiencing increases in the 70 to 90
percent range and one subject
experiencing an increase of 145 percent
which I'll note I don't take that
completely at face value I kind of think
they probably just had a bad pre-test
number like just not a great test uh
because that's that's a pretty extreme
outlier but in terms of just the general
variability we see very similar to
hypertrophy
um and it is tough with with uh MVC uh
you know with an isometric test like
this
um because I think some people say well
what do you mean a bad Baseline test you
know but it can be difficult especially
with untrained folks like it's pretty
easy with a bench press because it's
like well you're going to unrack the bar
and it's either gonna pin you to the
bench or it isn't right but with an MVC
test it's like okay push as hard as you
can against this pad and by the way you
never do leg extensions but push against
this as a leg extension as hard as you
possibly can and then you just have to
say like
was that did you do your best and
they're like yeah and you're like are
you are you certain though and like you
can have some some things in place to
try to uh alleviate the shortcomings of
that to the best of your ability but
sometimes you do just get a crappy
Baseline test Oh yeah and when you're
assessing 585 subjects the odds of
having one bad test in there is around a
hundred percent right yeah yeah uh so
yeah so that's talking about hypertrophy
and strength to this point uh like I
said I I'm gonna touch on aerobic
fitness as well
um so a classic study the Heritage study
uh from I think it started in in maybe
the late 80s uh through the 90s and this
uh the Heritage study itself is really
cool if if you're someone who's
interested in uh aerobic training in
general heritability of uh trainability
and and general fitness characteristics
the Heritage study was a huge trial
absolute classic definitely worth
looking into
um but the particular paper resulting
from that study that I'm going to talk
about here title was familial
aggregation of VO2 max response to
exercise training colon results from the
Heritage study from Bouchard and
colleagues in 1999 and this study very
similar to the Hue ball study big sample
size 481 total subjects previously
sedentary
and they completed 20 weeks of a
standardized aerobic training program on
a cycle ergometer twice per week and the
researchers assessed absolute VO2 max
before and after training so not MLS per
kg per minute but just total MLS per
minute
um
and the the typical gains in this study
were around 400 MLS uh gain in VO2 max
but we see the same sort of normal
distribution here as well with the
people again previously sedentary
subjects uh people who when you put them
on an aerobic training program you
should expect to see gains in aerobic
fitness the people with the absolute
worst responses actually experience
small decreases in aerobic fitness and
the people who had the absolute best
responses increase their absolute VO2
max by more than a liter per minute so
about two and a half times uh as large
of gains as the average so similar types
of variability as we see with
hypertrophy and strength
um which is to say very very substantial
variability and then finally to address
gains in hypertrophy in a pretty
systematic way
um I happen to have a little bit of
information on hand from the barbalia
investigation we did a couple years ago
the details of that aren't worth getting
into here that would be a huge diversion
huge rabbit hole look at us practicing
restraint yeah a new thing for the
podcast uh by the way you did a really
good job editing the last episode oh
thank you for the listeners I got very
sidetracked on some dumb [ __ ] during
Eric's segment uh and I felt very bad
about it but hopefully you didn't notice
because Eric is the magic of editing yes
um anyway so if you're interested in uh
learning more about statistics and how
one might go about
uh looking into
sketchy looking research maybe check out
the article it'll be linked in the show
notes but one of the things that that we
were interested in in that investigation
was what is the typical variability we
see in strength gains after uh a
resistance training program the reason
we were interested in this is the
studies by barbalio and colleagues
reported uh very very low variability
and strength gains like you know if a
training program added 20 kilos to
people squats on average they might
report like 20 plus or minus 2 kilos
like basically everyone gained between
15 and 25 kilos without much variability
which seemed pretty low so uh we had an
archive of like 83 studies that that I
had uh looked into for just like various
meta-analysis projects previously so it
was an unbiased sample that we weren't
just cherry picking for the purposes of
this particular investigation
where we could basically look and see
like hey in in the literature as a whole
in a pretty large group of studies what
is the typical variability we see in
strength gains and that was Quantified
in terms of what's called a Cohen's DZ
value
um which all that is is average gains in
a particular strength measure divided by
the standard deviation for the gains so
for example if in a study people put 20
plus or minus 10 kilos on their bench
press That's mean of 20 divided by
standard deviation of 10 that's a
Cohen's DZ value of 2. so the typical
Cohen's DZ value we saw kind of the
weighted average from this whole sample
of studies was about 1.6
uh and so just to put that in context uh
a Cohen's bz value of 1.6 means that if
there's a training intervention or the
typical gain or the average gain in
strength is 20 kilos that means within
one standard deviation you're looking at
uh on the low end a gain of 7.5 kilos
and on the top end a gain of 32 and a
half kilos so we're we're certainly not
talking about outliers here just within
one standard deviation of the mean
you're looking at a a difference in
strength gains of more than four-fold so
you know a an increase of 32 and a half
kilos is more than four times greater
than seven and a half kilos so that's
again just within a single standard
deviation within two standard deviations
you're looking at on the low end a
decrease of 5 kilos up to an increase of
45 kilos and so that's that's normal
[ __ ] again again we're not talking about
outliers here we're talking from the
2.5th percentile up to the 97.5
percentile uh so that's kind of where
most normal responses would fall so you
know uh that's but I think of that
though think of the the number of people
who if it's like you and your training
partner hypothetically you're both
pretty similar at Baseline you both do
the same program together one person
gains 42 kilograms the other person
loses three and it's like yeah that that
checks out yeah like those those seem
like extreme responses but we're again
we're staying within two standard
deviations of the mean here like that's
that's just perfectly normal stuff that
you would observe all the time uh and
then just in terms of not so much gains
and strength gains and muscle gains and
aerobic fitness but just kind of like
real world data on how strong people
actually are so back back in 2015 I sent
out a survey to the stronger by science
audience
um asking you know basically hey if
you're training pretty hard for either
powerlifting specifically or like power
lifting style training fill out this
survey uh there were a lot of things in
the survey but one of the things I asked
about or two of the things I asked about
were how long have you been training and
what is your one rep max Squad binge and
deadlift
um
and I I want to talk about this just
variability in terms of how strong
people actually are
relative to how long they've been
training because I think that there's
[Music]
um
an unfortunate facet of the strength
training content landscape is the
concept of strength standards tables
um which I think
outside of competitive environments are
virtually worthless like if you are
actually competing in powerlifting and
you might want to know if you're like a
class 3 lifter or a Master Level lifter
or whatever like you can look at those
tables and see how you stack up because
there's a purpose there like that's
that's saying how relatively competitive
are you compared to your peers in this
Sports you compete in but most strength
standards tables are like hey a novice
benches this much in intermediate level
lifter benches this much in expert level
lifter benches this much just kind of
assuming that how strong you are is a
pure uh function of Simply how long
you've been training without really
accounting for virtually anything else
including just how well people respond
to training like you you could be
in expert level trainee who just
responds pretty poorly to resistance
training on average you put in you know
20 years under the bar uh you know what
you're doing you've you've gotten the
gains that are available to you but
those gains are just smaller than other
folks and it could be demoralizing to
look at a table like that and say oh
well you're you're a early intermediate
level deadlifter
um you've been a beginner for 13 years
congratulations yeah so I I think that
those are are generally unhelpful simply
because of the variability we see in
terms of how strong people get when
they're actually training pretty hard to
get strong so
uh again like within this one survey
within our audience with I will note a
biased sample like so I'm not saying
that this is how strong the average
person gets when after they've been
training for X period of time like these
are people who are training with the
express intent of trying to get as
strong as possible in squat bench and
deadlift so you know this probably won't
generalize to the typical gym you go to
unless you happen to train at a
powerlifting gym but just to give some
examples here after six to 12 months of
training the the typical male or like
the average uh one rep max squat
strength for a male lifter uh in this
survey was about 150 kilos which makes
sense
um you know from spending a lot of time
coaching power lifters training and
power lifting gyms if a new lifter comes
in and they they devote themselves to
lifting pretty hard you know three plate
Squad within a year like that's that's a
very realistic thing that that you see
all the time
um but yeah the the average was like 150
kilos which is 330 pounds but
the standard deviation was like 35 kilos
so when you go plus or minus two
standard deviations from the mean the
bottom end of that range is 176 pounds
about 80 kilos the top end of that range
is about 220 kilos or about 485 pounds
so you know we're not again even talking
about outliers here but some people
after six to 12 months like not to be a
hater they're still just not
particularly strong like if if you put
in a year under the bar and your one rep
max is still 175 like uh
you know you might be looking around at
your peers and say like man they it
seems like other people are gaining
strength faster than me is is there's
something wrong here and I would say
probably not I mean you're you're not an
outlier On The Low End uh you just have
a smaller than average response to
resistance training and on the top end
like yeah like I I know a handful of
people who've squatted close to 500 or
over 500 within their first year of
lifting
um and those folks are just very
fortunate but again we're not even
talking about outliers here like that's
like the 97.5 percentile a similar
number similar numbers for women after
six to 12 months of lifting uh the
average squat was 90 kilos so that's
about 200 pounds uh but anything from 30
kilos or 66 pounds up to 150 kilos or
330 pounds were perfectly normal
responses again that's within two
standard deviations of the mean so like
just in terms of how strong people get
after training for comparable periods of
time there's huge huge variability here
and again just to reiterate I'm not
talking about outliers I'm talking about
plus or minus two standard deviations
from the mean which is where most people
fall and so if you're concerned like hey
I I seem to be experiencing smaller
strength gains than most people am I
atypical is something wrong probably not
like you probably fall within this sort
of range I'm talking about uh there
there's a very very good uh probability
that you do
so the next question here is is why why
do we see this amount of variability in
responses to training resistance
training aerobic training Etc
and
it's hard to say for for methodological
reasons but uh one of the contributors
almost assuredly is just genetics like
some people like they they just got a
better genetic draw for training than
other people did like if you look at
professional athletes in just about any
sport they pick better parents for for
their sport than you did and that's why
they're a pro and you're not
um but it's hard to say it's hard to put
a super precise estimate on exactly the
extent to which genetics per se
influence these things and this is
beyond the scope of this segment
um but I am somewhat skeptical of like
super precise estimates of heritability
um just because like
just because of like the methodology of
how those studies work and like I said
that's that's too big of a of a rabbit
hole to go down
um but like the the way that you would
typically try to estimate the
heritability of a particular trait is
you look to see uh when when people go
on the same sort of training
intervention how similar are responses
in people who are closely related so
parents and their children siblings
twins Etc compared to people who aren't
related so you know random person here
random person from some completely
different family you just kind of
aggregate that and look to see do people
who are related have responses to
training that are more similar than
people who aren't related on average and
if you see more similarity in family
clusters versus people outside of those
family clusters that that very strongly
suggests that there's a genetic
component
um and and that's what we see in all of
this stuff and like I said I I don't
like this is like we we talk about
sometimes on the podcast taking research
seriously versus literally I don't take
the precise heritability estimates
literally but I do think you can take
them seriously
um so there's very good evidence that
there is a genetic component to all of
this stuff but it's hard to say
precisely how large it is
um but I mean the genetic component is
there so uh one example is as of 2011 uh
22 specific genes had been discovered
that were uh strongly associated with a
quote strength power phenotype moving
beyond genetics uh other things
certainly matter as well uh you know
determining or being related to how well
you'll respond to training so you know
are you taking care of nutrition do you
have lifestyle factors that uh generally
promote gains in Fitness or generally
detract from them like are you sleeping
enough do you simply have enough time to
train uh is your life so stressful that
you can't recover particularly well all
of those things will certainly matter
um and then specifically for uh
hypertrophy there are a lot of little
things that we know to be predictive at
least in some circumstances of how well
people will respond to a hypertrophy
stimulus
uh and and citations for all of these
will be in the show notes but for
example satellite cell and myonuclei
responses seem to be predictive of uh
hypertrophy responses so people who have
larger elevations in Satellite cell
content and greater myonuclear accretion
following training tend to experience
more hypertrophy than those who don't
um particular micro RNA responses seem
to be predictive of training responses
that's from uh 2014 I believe study by
Davidson and colleagues uh ribosome
biogenesis seems to be predictive uh
which that one makes a lot of intuitive
sense if you think back to high school
biology ribosomes are the actual little
like cellular machines that build
proteins and so that's kind of like a
precondition for being able to build a
lot of additional new contractile
protein in your muscles so if two people
undergo go the same training stimulus
and one of them only has a small
elevation in ribosome content in their
muscles and one of them has a large
elevation in ribosome content of their
muscles who knows why those uh ribosome
responses differ but if they do the one
who winds up with more ribosomes will
just have more little cellular machines
that are capable of building those
proteins that their DNA is asking them
to build a particular myokine responses
seem to be predictive of gains in
hypertrophy and uh Androgen receptor
density although Androgen levels
themselves within the normal
physiological range might be associated
with hypertrophy but don't don't
actually seem to be all that predictive
but Androgen receptor density does seem
to be and those are just things we know
and there are probably half a dozen or
more additional things that are all
associated with how well you'll respond
to training that just simply haven't
been discovered yet
um
and also these aren't all independent
things like they are also probably
associated with your genetics and your
lifestyle so uh there are plenty of
things that can influence how well
someone will respond to training
um and and just one other thing I guess
to acknowledge here is at least when
we're talking about the research on
response variability to training one of
the things that needs to be acknowledged
is uh the potential impact of
measurement error or just day-to-day
biological fluctuations so you know if
um
let's say that you undergo a training
program and in real terms you put five
pounds on your bench over 10 weeks or
something like that so not a not a huge
gain in strength but you you did
increase strength like if you went to
the gym at the start of the program on
the absolute best conceivable day for
testing your bench press maybe you could
do 185 pounds and also under optimal
circumstances after the training program
you could do 190 pounds but you know
let's say during the the pre-testing
assessments things just weren't going
your way uh or no no it's the opposite
uh let's say during the pre-training
assessment everything was going your way
you felt great
um you know everything was just firing
right your strength was there and you do
hit 185 and it's a very good strength
test and then let's say 10 weeks later
you are like you're you're kind of true
unbiased like getting rid of day-to-day
fluctuations your actual strength has
gone up five pounds but let's just say
that on the day that the post training
assessment occurred it just wasn't your
day you had a shitty night of sleep the
night before uh like maybe your shoulder
feels tight for no apparent reason you
just slept on it funny uh your your
girlfriend or boyfriend just broke up
with you like you don't feel good when
you walk into the lab they test your
bench press strength and it's just not a
good day in the gym and you hit 180. so
you know the result from that study
would suggest your bench press strength
went down five pounds but in real terms
it actually went up five pounds you just
had a bad a bad day of testing so some
of the variability we see in responses
to training are almost assuredly due to
stuff like that just basic measurement
error or day-to-day fluctuations and
strength uh or general performance but
like I want to make this very clear the
magnitude of different responses we see
between people are way larger than could
be attributed to just technical
measurement error or day-to-day
fluctuations and strength like if if one
person is experience of experiencing a
five kilo decrease in squat strength and
one person experiences a 50 kilo
increase in squat strength those two
people didn't experience the same
strength gains and just had a good or
bad day of testing per year post like
that's those are true like very
quantifiable differences between people
but I I did just want to make that note
because uh you know when you're talking
about
any of this stuff like it's important to
keep stuff like measurement error or
just day-to-day fluctuations in mind but
those factors like that can account to
anywhere close to the sheer magnitude of
a variation we see
all right so
uh the next and final uh section here is
is what can we do about this stuff so if
you are someone who has been training
for a while you you think you're
training pretty smart you think you're
training pretty hard uh you're doing
training that should be effective but
you just look around and you think man
like I I just don't seem to be
experiencing the gains that a lot of
other people in my gym are my training
partners are I don't seem to be getting
the responses to training that I see
Elsewhere on social media what are some
things that I could potentially do to
help Rectify that and and start making
better gains
um so the first thing you can do and
this is
may sound like a bit of a cop-out but
it's true it's just try to make sure you
have your ducks in a row outside the gym
so
you know if you're not
experiencing particularly large strength
gains training doesn't seem to be going
well but you're consistently sleeping
four or five hours per night uh just
because you're getting up to tomfoolery
you can't turn off Netflix can't get off
social media like your lifestyle would
theoretically allow you to sleep eight
or nine hours per night but just just
due to sheer pig-headedness you're
sleeping five hours per night like I
don't know maybe try to address that
before you say like I just don't respond
well to training
um or you know if you uh have the means
to consume like 1.6 grams of protein per
kilogram body mass but uh you just don't
like to and so you're consuming like 40
grams of protein per day
ah you know if you're not experiencing
much muscle growth that could be
contributing so I I don't want to make
it sound like everyone has the same
capacity to fully get their ducks in a
row outside the gym like you know if if
poor sleep and Recovery is uh leading to
smaller strength gains less muscle
growth but the reason that you're not
sleeping as much is because you recently
had kids or because you have to work two
jobs to make ends meet or any number of
other things like you know I I I don't
want to make it sound like oh yeah like
if you don't do if you don't uh design
your lifestyle to look like a
professional athlete it's because you
don't want it bad enough like I'm
certainly not saying that but to to the
extent that is feasible if there are
ways that you can improve your nutrition
improve your recovery that you simply
haven't done to this point even though
they're they're feasible and reasonable
for you to do so maybe try those things
first yeah that that really hits close
to home right now because as you know
um we had a hurricane rolling into town
and so what does my girlfriend do she
just leaves you know she just gets out
of town and leaves me with the cat
unbelievable so I'm over here trying to
take care of the cat it's it's a
full-time job trying to take care of one
cat so like my sleep my schedule it's
all out the window you know so I'm I'm
doing my best but man chasing Izzy
around the house has not been easy it's
tough to be a single dad yeah yeah uh so
the next thing you can do and this this
is going to sound quite obvious
um but it needs to be said is just keep
training so if you're experiencing
relatively small or relatively slow
gains in Fitness uh gains and strength
gains in muscle mass Etc
small gains do add up over time
um and you know that that is almost
self-evidently true but let's bring
bring a study into it just so we can
look at some data so this study is from
Ralston colleagues from 2015 the title
is separate effects of intensity and
amount of exercise on inter-individual
cardiorespiratory Fitness response and
so in this group uh or in this study
three different groups of people trained
five times per week for 24 weeks uh one
of the groups basically just trained
easy so in in each of their training
sessions
um the total amount of work they did was
relatively small and they performed it
at a low intensity in another group they
also exercised at a low intensity but uh
the total volume of work they did was
twice as large as the first group and
then the third group uh they did a lot
of work per session and they also
trained at a higher intensity city than
the other two groups and what you see in
all three groups so they they assess
cardio respiratory Fitness at four weeks
eight weeks 16 weeks and 24 weeks and in
all three groups what you see
is that after just four weeks of
training there were quite a few
individuals in every group that would be
classified as non-responders including
the group that was doing quite a lot of
training so a high volume of training
and at a high intensity
um 11 out of 31 subjects would have been
classified as non-responders after four
weeks and in the group basically just
training easy so low intensity and a low
total volume of training uh 20 out of 34
subjects would have been classified as
non-responders so those were people who
experienced uh either increases or
decreases in aerobic fitness that were
smaller than the than the typical
measurement error for the equipment they
were using but then after 24 weeks of
training in the really easy training
group the number of non-responders had
gone down from 20 to 15 in kind of that
middle group the higher volume of low
intensity training the number of
responders had gone down from 25 to just
9 and in the high intensity and high
volume group the number of
non-responders had gone down from 11 to
zero so you know just simply continuing
the same training intervention will just
lead to larger gains over time
um as long as you are making progress
progress adds up
uh and this isn't like over like a four
year timeline we were talking about 24
weeks right yeah it's six months yeah
uh the next thing you can do if you're
not experiencing the the sorts of gains
you would like to see is in
again like this will potentially seem
obvious but again it Bears sane is just
to train more or train harder so the the
prior study is a great illustration of
this uh the the paper by Ross so you
know as the amount of training increases
so the total volume and as the intensity
of training increased the average gains
in cardiorespiratory Fitness got larger
and the proportion of people who would
have been classified as non-responders
got smaller another study that I'm
pretty sure we've talked about on the
podcast before also relates to this this
was by Montero and lundby in 2017 title
is refuting the myth of non-response to
exercise training colon non-responders
do respond to higher dose of training
that's a good way to get people to read
your paper or talk about it if your
first thing is refuting the myth of
blank yeah just like a a really strong
audacious declaratory statement men at
minimum that's going to get people to
click on your study it is I I said that
a little bit facetiously but I I
genuinely do appreciate it because like
we go through the journal sweep every
month for mass and we you know we sort
it by title and there's no fewer than
like 75 studies that that just start
with effects of some boring [ __ ] on some
other [ __ ] yeah you know so I I
appreciate a bold title oh for sure uh I
I mean look click bait Works folks
whether whether you like it or not and
we're like buzz or like clickbait works
just as well in on PubMed as it does on
BuzzFeed or like YouTube like it's
generalizably true we live in the world
of Click bait it's time to just accept
it
um you know and here's the deal as well
like occasionally we'll put a clickbait
title on something and people in the
comments like not many but occasionally
they'll be like ah this is clickbait
you clicked on it though that's that's
all I'm saying like congratulations you
played yourself it worked yeah um anyway
so
in this study there were five groups of
people uh who trained for six weeks uh
at 60 minutes per session and uh the
groups either trained one two three four
or five times per week and so basically
the total volume of training and
training intensity was the same in all
five groups so the total of all total
volume of training was simply determined
by how many days per week they were
training uh and they found that for the
groups training one two and three times
per week there were a reasonable number
of folks who were non-responders in
those groups again people experiencing
gains in aerobic fitness that were
smaller than the measurement error for
for the device being used to assess
Fitness and there were more
non-responders training ones per week
than twice per week and more
non-responders training twice per week
than three times per week and there were
no people who would who would have been
classified as non-responders in the four
and five times per week groups and then
in the second part of the study they
took the folks who were classified as
non-responders during the first six
weeks and said hey you're going to do
six more weeks of training but you're
gonna do an additional two sessions per
week so if you were previously just
training once per week now you're gonna
train three times per week if you're
training two times per week now you're
gonna train four times per week and if
you were training three times per week
now you're gonna be training five times
per week so those same people who were
previously deemed non-responders
following their first six weeks of
training they just do more training for
another six weeks and uh tldr uh none of
them were non-responders anymore just
increasing the dose of exercise
increased the extent to which they
responded to it and like this this
likely generalizes to resistance
training as well like we know that uh
training volume is a factor that is
strongly associated with hypertrophy
response answers so you know if you're
if you're not seeing the muscle growth
you want and your training is overall
fairly low volume
like you'll probably respond better to
training by increasing that volume a
little bit
all right uh so those those are I think
the most obvious things you could do
just uh stick at it uh try to get your
ducks in a row outside the gym and uh
just try training more yeah I was
smiling because I know someone's gonna
get in the comments and say like oh Greg
thanks for the evidence-based segment
that tells people to to do more and do
better yeah I I mean but
like that is true uh but like I I do
think it's worth so
a dynamic that I think exists is
um like folks who respond worse to
training than most people on average uh
like if they do say anything about it uh
or you know maybe complain about it a
little bit like they'll often be met
with just a wall of responses saying
like well have you tried trying like
like why don't you just train harder
um and like that I think is often mint
in kind of a
um
ah what's the way not off-putting what
like it's it's just like kind of in a
dismissive way yeah
um so what I'm at least attempting to do
here is to not assume that everyone
who's responding worse to training than
average isn't trying and isn't putting
in the work
um like I I fully I fully believe they
are and they they just got a bad genetic
draw and like it is what it is yeah and
so I'm trying to say like couched within
that context
unfortunately it is still true that
training more will probably be
beneficial and I don't mean that in like
a dismissive way like I just mean it in
a it is probably true way yeah and we've
mentioned in the past in various places
that we do tend to lean toward the
empiricist perspective when it comes to
you know reviewing evidence and I do
think it's it's beneficial it's very
easy to say well if you just do it for
longer I assume it will start working I
think it is very reassuring to say oh
yeah here is empirical evidence of
people who in the first phases of
training struggled but those gains did
materialize over time like it is nice to
have that confirmation even though it's
not a dazzling theory of do it for
longer yeah you know I I mean a good
chunk of science is just confirming
things that we already very strongly
suspected to be true yeah and this is
just kind of in that category yeah all
right uh so the fourth thing you could
do is just measure more variables
um here is another nice uh strong
declaratory audacious statement from
churchward Vin and colleagues in 2015.
title of this study is there are no
non-responders to resistance type
exercise training in older men and women
um you know it's another great thing
about title start started to uh butt in
here but yeah not only are they more fun
and clickable but if you were the type
of person who only reads abstracts with
this one you don't even have to do that
that is true you just read the title
correct wow I know everything I wanted
to know yeah and I mean the title itself
is a pretty good tldr
um so in this study it was a
retrospective analysis of responses to
12 and 24 weeks of training in uh men
and women who were at least 65 years old
at the start of the study and uh pre and
post training they assessed lean body
mass via dexa type 1 and type 2 muscle
fiber cross-sectional area via biopsy
one rep max strength for leg press and
knee extensions and physical function
test chair rise time test those were
assessed at Baseline after 12 weeks of
training and after 24 weeks of training
and the thing to note is in this study
there were plenty of quote unquote
non-responders for each discrete
variable like there were plenty of
people who didn't gain that much lean
mass plenty of people who didn't
experience robust increases in fiber
cross-sectional area a handful of people
people who didn't experience strength
gains Etc but every single individual in
this study
experienced meaningful increases in at
least one of these things so like and
the other thing to note kind of going
back to the to the second point of just
keep training for each discrete variable
there were fewer people who were deemed
non-responders at 24 weeks then at 12
weeks and and here are two good quotes
just from the abstract
non-responsiveness was not apparent in
any subject as a positive adaptive
response on at least one training
outcome was apparent in every subject
and quote the level of responsiveness
was strongly affected by the duration of
the exercise intervention with more
positive responses following more
prolonged exercise training so
like
this this will also I think be
hard to say without
potentially coming off as dismissive but
like there are there are benefits to
training that you probably care about
that may not be the the number one main
thing you're interested in that if you
just kind of are willing to expand the
scope of the responses that you're that
you're willing to be interested in and
assess and look at
there will probably be something that's
going right for you so
if you're trying to
you know just just gain as much muscle
as possible head to toe put on some
strength Etc uh and you're you're a low
responder to hypertrophy style training
you know it could be that that becoming
a mass monster isn't in the cards but
you might have a muscle group or two
that responds pretty well so if you get
more granular with your assessments and
instead of just looking at like total
lean mass you kind of look at like oh
I'm gonna take a upper arm circumference
measure lower arm circumference measure
upper thigh calf waist chest whatever
like you might find a few muscles that
do respond pretty well you can keep
track of them be proud of them uh if
you're trying to build muscle and get
stronger like there are
just fewer strength non-responders than
hypertrophy non-responders
um so I mean like even if you're not
putting that much muscle on your frame
you will probably still get stronger and
become generally more physically capable
like there there are
positive training related things that
are happening which may not necessarily
be the the just level A1 type thing you
were the most interested in
um you know like like there there will
probably still be plenty of of uh
physical aspects that are moving in the
right direction so if you're willing to
just kind of like expand your horizons
and look at more total variables you
will probably find something that that
is going pretty well for you I'm glad
that you brought up the term mass
monster because it is something I wanted
to clear up a lot of people have asked
me why I trans because I had a really
good thing going I was a very successful
Pro natural bodybuilder and a lot of
people ask why I transitioned to Pro
natural classic bodybuilding which is a
pretty huge change of direction for me
and it really comes down to like for
some people being a mass monster just
isn't in the cards like you mentioned
but you know for me it was more of a
stylistic thing I was looking around the
the natural bodybuilding landscape
and it was just getting grotesque I mean
you had these Mass monsters getting on
stage 160
165 pounds on these Pro natural
bodybuilding stages so I'm glad that
that we've expanded the sport and opened
up classic bodybuilding for a more
a more streamlined and frankly less
grotesque physique yeah totally fair
yeah uh okay so the the fifth thing you
could potentially do is experiment with
different training Styles so uh I'm
gonna go back to the carniero paper that
I uh talked about quite a bit two
episodes ago uh title is different load
intensity transition schemes to avoid
plateau and no response and lean body
mass gain in post-menopausal women and
so I'm not going to talk about this
study in a ton of detail again because I
I already did two episodes ago
um but just as a very brief refresher
this was a 24-week crossover study where
subjects completed 12 weeks of training
at a moderate intensity so 8 to 12 rep
max loads and 12 weeks of training at a
low intensity so 27 to 31 rep max loads
in a randomized order so half of them
started with moderate load training for
12 weeks followed by low load training
for 12 weeks and the other half just
went the opposite order 12 weeks of low
load training followed by 12 weeks of
moderate load training
and as I discussed in the previous
segment
some individuals who did really really
well with moderate load training really
didn't do well with low load training
they experienced a ton of hypertrophy
training in the 8 to 12 or at max range
and experienced either much smaller
gains in hypertrophy or even experience
decreases in lean soft tissue mass of
the thighs following 12 weeks of low
load training and vice versa some people
did really really well with low load
training and just really didn't get much
if anything out of moderate load
training so
it could simply be a matter of uh
finding a training style that that works
well for you which may not be the
training style that works the best on
average and specifically to this
conversation about low responders High
responders to training non-responders to
training
um one thing we can do with the data in
this in this study since uh like since
individual results were reported is you
can just look to see uh following 12
weeks of training who would have been
termed a low responder to train versus a
high responder to training just using a
median split like who got better gains
than average versus who got worse gains
than average uh well not average 50th
percentile you know what I'm saying
um and then after 24 weeks so after an
additional 12 weeks of training who who
who who was previously a high responder
is now still a high responder uh versus
who was a low responder who is now a
high responder who is a who is a low
responder who's still a low responder
who was a high responder who's now a low
responder you know just just looking to
see how many of those categorizations
would have been shuffled up and then
also
um you know during the first 12 weeks of
training how many people would have
initially been termed non-responders who
suddenly became responders after an
additional 12 weeks of training with a
different training style and again
non-responder being defined here as
people who experienced increases in lean
soft tissue mass of the thigh that were
smaller than the kind of technical
measurement error of the machine being
used and so when you do that analysis
a full third of the people uh in this
study their uh like High versus low
responder classification would have
flipped so uh out of 24 total people in
the study
um
eight of them flipped so either they
were previously High responders after 12
weeks of training and became low
responders after 24 weeks of training or
they were low responders after 12 weeks
of training and became High responders
after 24 weeks of training and at times
this was actually a pretty
pretty intense changes so uh just
looking at at the individual results
following the full 24 weeks of training
the individuals in the study who
experienced the third and fourth most
total amount of hypertrophy following
the full 24 weeks of training would have
been classified as low responders
following the first 12 weeks of training
so you know that that's uh just just
Downstream of spending 12 weeks of
training doing a style of training that
they simply responded much much better
to than they did the style of training
in the first 12 weeks and then for
responders versus non-responders like in
in 12-week studies we typically see that
between like a quarter and a third of
folks you would term non-responders like
people who experience gains and strength
or gains in muscle mass smaller than
kind of the typical measurement error
just day-to-day biological variability
uh and that's what we saw in this study
after 12 weeks so out of 24 subjects
seven of them would have been termed
non-responders after the first three
months of training they experienced
gains in lean soft tissue mass of the
thighs that were smaller than the
measurement error of the machine after
24 weeks of training only two people
would have still been termed
non-responders so both continuing to
train and finding a training style that
worked better for them cut the
non-response rate down from 7 out of 24
to 2 out of 24. so
um
yeah like
it's
I I think that people
on the whole
uh do
do have maybe a bit too much faith in
kind of the the uh Collective
unconscious of the fitness community and
not enough faith in their own experience
and their their ability to interpret
their own experience like I I see a lot
of people who uh you know go online and
say like hey I want to get stronger what
programs will help me do that they look
around they find a program that a lot of
people have done generally has good
reviews seem to work well and they do it
and it doesn't work particularly well
for them either they don't get stronger
at all or they don't get much stronger
and they just kind of throw their hands
up and say well this is a good program
it works like it's worked for thousands
of people it didn't seem to work for me
so man like I I guess getting stronger
just isn't in the cards
um
whereas like I I think probably a more
productive thing to do would be
either to look at kind of what the what
the characteristics of that training
program were the the overall level of
volume overall level of intensity uh
training frequency
and and just say like okay that didn't
work let's just do the opposite like if
it was a low volume program let's try a
high volume program if it was a high
intensity program let's try a lower
intensity program and just and just you
know basically start troubleshooting
from there like I know what what didn't
work let's just try something different
and see if that works or you know just
kind of going back to the well and
saying hey let's try to find another
generally effective pretty well reviewed
program that doesn't look anything at
all like that one that didn't work for
me like that's
um I I think that uh more people should
do that like don't don't uh so I mean
and this this can even
go to levels that I
like I don't want to sound mean but to
to an extent that like I find I have a
difficult time empathizing with uh like
like someone will start training and get
on generally it's just like a typical
linear progression type program like
starting strength strong lift something
like that and they put in two years
under the bar uh on a single training
program and
like they've been hitting a wall
deloading building back up hitting the
wall deloading building back up over
that entire time span
never built much muscle never got
particularly stronger but it's like well
people say these are good programs and I
should be able to write it to a 405
Squad and I only squat
220. so like I guess I just need to keep
doing this
um
and then you know they just don't get
there and decide like oh well resistance
train just isn't for me or I must be
[ __ ] up and doing something wrong
I would say like the only thing you
[ __ ] up there is just sticking with a
program for two years that clearly
doesn't work for you yeah um
yeah like I I I I don't know like this
is another rant but I I think that like
the
there's been so much so much invective
thrown the way of of pro quote-unquote
program Hoppers over the years then now
there are a lot of people who are afraid
to ever change their training program
yeah
um
and yeah like sometimes you just need to
change your training program yeah I was
gonna ask you about that because you
know you you look at
um you know you you talked about you
know things you can do about it keep
training uh potentially train more train
harder and those two uh approaches you
know someone who's who is very uh
you know someone who speaks very poorly
of quote-unquote program Hoppers they're
they're hearing that and saying Hell
yeah that's exactly what I've been
saying but but you know it is important
to recognize that simply trying more
than one thing does not make you a
program Hopper right so like yeah if you
if you try a program and and within the
first four to eight weeks it's not
working but you gen generally enjoy it
you know maybe that is a situation where
you say okay well maybe you know try
some modifications to do a little more
alter volume intensity or maybe just
stick with it for eight more weeks and
see if the needle starts moving but yeah
like you said I mean the the two things
that that do get a little bit baffling
is the people who
are 200 pounds away from their squat
goal you know it's they've been doing
this program it's got them like 10
pounds over the last year and it's like
if you think you're gonna make up the
next 200 pounds how is that going to
occur yeah unless you're going to be
doing this for 40 years and and like
that's the the plan here you know like
just mathematically how do you think of
doing the same thing with this rate of
progress is going to get you to where
where your stated goal is well if
scientists ever solve human aging like
yeah and now you have a 500 year Runway
maybe yeah but but you you do sometimes
see these situations where you're like
you extrapolate out the gains you're
getting and if anything they're going to
get worse not better over time if you
keep doing you know it should be a
somewhat logarithmic generally speaking
Yeah doing the same exact approach
um but yeah you look at it and you're
like maybe program hopping you know with
a little caveat that you're giving the
program enough time to do something
maybe that's actually the right path
forward uh and like you said there's
also a tendency in the space for people
to be so hung up on the collective
understanding that they reject their own
experience that's literally right in
front of their eyes and like I have
observed some internet chatter where
someone's like you know I tried this
program that has less set volume than
the going meta-analysis that Everyone
likes and it seemed to work for me but
that's impossible and it's like well
it's not though yeah it literally
happened yeah and we should expect a
great deal of variability from person to
person because of all the reasons you've
covered so it is important that like
some people are so uh dismissive of
program Hoppers that some people get
locked into this area where they're like
well whatever works for everyone has to
be best for me and if I ever change that
then I've demonstrated a lack of
commitment to the program which is bad
yes yeah yeah so if you're if you're
trying new training programs every two
weeks
yeah then you're a program Hopper like
yeah you got to give it time to see if
it's working but if you've been on a
program for three to six months uh uh
and and you've given it a real honest
shot and it's not doing much for you try
something else like that that's not
program hopping that's uh
like I know this is an apocryphal quote
but the the quote that's often
attributed to Einstein like insanity is
doing the same thing over and over and
expecting a different response
um
I I think that applies here yeah
all right and then uh the last thing
that you could potentially do is take an
even more uh expansive view of the
benefits you would like to see from
training
um
and or potentially not just try a
different style of programming for a
particular Fitness outcome but
potentially just see if there's other
forms of training that that click better
with you so uh for example like
you could very well be a low responder
for strength and hypertrophy and still
experience great improvements in blood
pressure blood lipids bone health uh
mood sleep
um uh decreasing the rate of cognitive
aging improved blood glucose regulation
and probably a half dozen other things
from continuing to train so like you may
not be seeing the gains in muscle mass
that you want uh or strength that you
want but training could still be doing a
ton of other positive things for you
that you know like like ultimately
ultimately I I think that
when you look back on it uh
uh as you're getting older like you're
you're probably not going to be like
that resentful or upset that you weren't
like the biggest guy at every gym you
went into but if you're you know getting
into your 70s and you're still in pretty
good health and you look around at some
of your other peers who didn't really do
much consistent exercise throughout
their lifespan and their like things are
starting to go downhill for them a
little bit you'll say you know what I
never got as big as I wanted to but I'm
I'm glad I did all of that training yeah
um
and then for like on on the topic of of
trying to maybe see if there's just an
entirely different style of training
that you respond well to and that you
like
um a study that I want to talk about by
car avirta and colleagues from 2011 uh
individual responses to combined
endurance and strength training in older
adults there were 53 sub there were
three groups in this study I'm only
going to talk about one of them but
there was a group of 53 subjects who did
21 weeks of both resistance and
endurance training uh and there's a
figure from the study that we can put up
on the screen here if you're watching on
YouTube uh but just looking at the
correlation in gains in VO2 Peak and uh
maximum voluntary contraction strength I
think I think of the quads is what they
were measuring
um there was no correlation at all
between those two things like people who
responded well to endurance training or
to the aerobic part of the intervention
um like that like responding well in
terms of gains in VO2 Peak was
completely unpredictive of whether you
would also gain a lot of strength uh if
you gained a lot of strength that was
completely unpredictive of whether you'd
experience large gains in aerobic
fitness uh and so
you know I I think that
um
I think that
oftentimes like
I I think a lot of this comes back to
like motivation almost like what why are
you training in the first place like
what what are you hoping to get out of
it uh and like I've I've talked to quite
a few people who
like
had been Lifting for a long like they
hit me up because they'd been Lifting
for a while and they they just weren't
seeing the responses to training that
they wanted
um
and you know
like I would be asking them like hey why
why are you doing this in the first
place like what what are you hoping to
achieve it's like oh well you know I'm
trying to get as as muscular and strong
as possible and it's like
yeah but why like what's what's
underpinning that and like for for a few
of them it was like well you know like
I've I've heard that it's it's good for
longevity like people who are who have
more strength and more muscle mass when
they hit like 50 60 years old tend to
have longer lifespans like ultimately
I'm just doing this to try to be healthy
so it's like man so first you don't you
don't need to be a mass monster in the
first place to do that
um
and second like if you're hitting me up
because you're you're so frustrated
about the the relatively poor responses
you're seeing to resistance training
you know that like
doing aerobic training is also good for
longevity uh why don't you give that a
shot and a handful of them gave it a
shot and they're like you know what like
I don't know why I was lifting in the
first place I never particularly liked
it it wasn't fun and uh guess what I
like biking or I like running thanks for
putting me down this road and so on one
hand kind of shooting myself in the foot
because I don't I don't put out aerobic
training information that is taking a
potential future customer out of my
revenue streams but uh ultimately I mean
I don't know man uh like so so
ultimately if you if you like lifting
um like if you're if you're coming at
this from a like like purely intrinsic
motivation like a lot of this shouldn't
really be an issue in the first place
like you know maybe you would just like
to see larger gains because you'd like
to make larger gains
um but if you have like a true intrinsic
motivation here especially if you're
kind of like process oriented about it
and you're lifting because you like to
lift uh you probably won't be the type
of person who's getting like super super
frustrated about this because like
whether or not you're getting super huge
and super strong like you're continuing
to lift because you like to uh if you've
made it to this point in the video
and
you're still thinking like man like I I
really want to be as big and strong as
possible but like this is really
frustrating because like
I don't really even like lifting that
much I just want what I can get out of
like what I've been told I will get out
of lifting
I think at that point it's it may not be
a terrible idea to just like assess
motivation and see like why are you
doing this in the first place because I
gotta tell you like I I also know plenty
of people who do respond really well to
training
who just like didn't like training all
that much and guess what they don't
stick with training
um like they just don't like they get
big and get strong and then just get
bored of it in five years and say yeah
like [ __ ] it I never liked doing that
I'm going to stop and then for them it
becomes like a fun fact where later in
life they're like oh yeah like 20 years
ago I was huge would you even believe it
yeah yeah yeah so you know if you're
if you are like that that frustrated
that that does suggest at least to some
extent a lack of like process oriented
intrinsic motivation so if you're going
down that road it it probably wouldn't
be a terrible idea to just try some
completely different form of exercise
that regardless of the gains you get
from it you just like doing it it's it's
fun and so so you're going to be much
more likely to stick with it and there
is a decent chance that if you're
frustrated because of the lack of gains
you're getting to resistance training
you very well could respond very well to
some other form of exercise like you
know maybe you've been Lifting for two
or three years you're not particularly
big you're not particularly strong you
start doing some aerobic training and
six months later you have a very
competitive 5K time like that that may
just be a more productive road to go
down yeah and I think this conversation
about broadening your horizons about
what training can look like and what it
can bring you that really resonates with
me in a way that really didn't have
anything to do with being frustrated
with my response to training like you
know that I've had a thing going on for
quite some time now with uh kind of like
a nerve entrapment that has made it very
very difficult to do
uh just about any squad or deadlift
variations without a pretty substantial
amount of pain
um like the type of pain that actually
isn't just like achy but really Alters
kind of day-to-day enjoyment of of Life
yeah uh and so you know I had the the
road to road to Athens segment where I
was like oh maybe I'll get back into
long distance running now unfortunately
that aggravated the exact same thing and
So eventually that became uh similarly
frustrating but it was the same idea of
like can I find a way to do exercise
that is enjoyable and brings me some of
these benefits like obviously it's not
going to make me huge but how will it
affect my mood my sleep thing you know
aging things like that so uh what you
know whether you're running into
frustration because of uh you know lack
of progress you know being dissatisfied
with your gains or you're running into
frustration because of the way you like
to train is currently not compatible
with what makes you feel good and you
have to make some uh some adjustments
whether they're temporary or permanent
uh pertaining to some limitations it is
sometimes helpful to go back to the
drawing board and have a broader scope
of what exercise looks like and what it
can do for you yeah yeah and I think
just on kind of like a metal level
um like I I think that it's worth asking
like whether you plan on like competing
in anything uh because like if you do
then it is probably worth being at least
a little concerned about like oh like
how how large are the are the gains I'm
experiencing how do my results stack up
to other people but like if not the
thing is like exercise is just good uh
aerobic exercise is good group exercise
is good resistance exercise is good like
it's just good to find things that get
you moving and so if if you don't have
like competitive aspirations in any
particular strength physique sport
aerobic sport like anything
just fine just fine things you enjoy
doing
um
and that should I mean that that should
take care of a lot of it
um
I mean yeah like there have been there
have been plenty of things in my I'm
like so I I think a pretty good example
for me at least like historically is
basketball like I've made no bones about
it basketball is my favorite sport I
like the way they dribble up and down
the court little little throwback for
the 90s kids listening
um but like that was a great lyric by
the way who was that Lil battle it was
little bow wow yeah I think from like
Mike yeah uh but yeah so I mean dude I'm
I'm like 5 10 on a good day uh and
I'm like relatively fast can jump
reasonably well have reasonably good
hand-eye coordination but like once I
got onto like the AAU circuit and like
uh like higher levels of basketball like
I mean I just I didn't pick the right
parents for it and so you know like I I
went from being among the better players
in like youth leagues I played in and
like uh for the school I played at to
being like one of the worst players uh
and you know on some of the teams I I
was on I didn't get that much time off
of the bench but like I don't know I
didn't care uh it was boring to sit on
the bench during the games but uh I mean
practice was still sick like because I
just love playing basketball
um
and so like yeah like I I had a strong
intrinsic motivation to keep doing it
even though at least at that level the
the results that I was seeing for the
work I was putting in were way way
smaller than than those of my peers but
I was like this is this is fine because
I I just like doing it it's fun yeah um
and so I mean it and I think one of the
things that helped me a lot with that is
like
I was competitive in the in the sense of
like you know this this is a sport
they're keeping score there's a winner
and a loser but by that time like in
high school
I already had the mindset of like
I can I can see where I'm at in this
sport like I'm not getting a D1
scholarship to play at the next level
I'm certainly not going pro so like
I'm doing this for fun and it's it's a
good time
um and so like yeah that's uh I that's a
perspective just just to keep in mind
like if you're doing something to
compete might be worth comparing
yourself against others if you're really
just doing it for personal satisfaction
longevity whatever
just just find things you like doing
um and if what you like doing that gets
you active differs from what someone on
the Internet is saying
you should be doing just ignore them
because
there's a extremely good chance they're
wrong like whatever sort of exercise you
like is almost assuredly good exercise
yep all right so let's just wrap this up
uh let's do it just a little a little
recap here uh and and some some
implications so the first thing
I'm going all the way back to the
beginning is almost no matter what
you're experiencing in the gym if you're
concerned man like I think I think
there's something wrong with me like
things don't seem to be going right just
take a deep breath it's okay there is an
incredibly good chance that whatever
you're experiencing is completely normal
completely okay completely fine there's
just
a tremendous degree of variability in
terms of the responses people see to
training
um that is like the the variability is
larger than I think people realize and
whatever you're experiencing is probably
within two standard deviations of the
mean very normal [ __ ] it's just people
experience very different responses to
training and and that applies to both
above and below average responses like
if you think like oh [ __ ] like am I am I
the god of resistance training because
I've only been lifting six months and I
squat 405 like no probably not like
you're doing better than average but
you're probably like that that is also
perfectly normal as well like it's above
average but that's that's not an outlier
response whatever you're experiencing is
probably just normal and fine
um
the next thing is uh
like just keep in mind as you're out
there on the internet
um or in or even in the gym like what
you see on a day-to-day basis that you
might be comparing yourself against uh
is almost assured to be a skewed sample
so uh like that's clearly true for
social media like the the people who pop
up in your discover feed or whatever for
physique Sports strength Sports whatever
those are almost always people who just
have very above average responses to
resistance training uh folks find that
interesting that's why they get more
likes that's why the algorithms are
serving them to you
um so what what you come across online
is an extremely skewed sample and if
you're using that to set your
expectations there's there's a decent
chance you'll you'll probably wind up
disappointed and think that even if
you're having like the perfectly average
response to training you will still
perceive it to be below average because
it's below the average of what you're
seeing on social media on a day-to-day
basis but what you're seeing on social
media is a severely skewed sample
um but even like what you see in the gym
is probably at least to some extent a
skewed sample as well like if if you go
in the weight room and most people at
your gym who you see lifting weights all
the time if they tend to be quite a bit
larger or uh stronger than you like that
is probably also a skewed sample because
the thing is like folks tend to
self-select into the forms of exercise
they respond well to and so if you're
seeing the same regulars going to the
gym all the time over months or years
those people who stick with training are
are generally people who have
on average above average responses to
training and that's probably why why
they stick with it compared to some
other form of exercise and this
generalizes as well like the people who
uh like if you go down to a local 5K
like not even some sort of like super
prestigious track and field event the
people competing in that 5K probably
have at least slightly better responses
to aerobic training than the average
person does which is why they're the
type of person who runs 5Ks and likes
doing that so
um yeah don't don't be hard on yourself
and just keep in mind that that what
you're seeing like there's a pretty
decent chance that you are being too
hard on yourself and thinking that what
you're experiencing is
further below average than it actually
is like plenty of power like and this is
true for competitors as well like plenty
of power lifters who
aren't even that competitive at local
meets maybe great responders to
resistance training it's just they're
not great responders to resistance
training compared to other people who
compete in this sport so
just keep all of that in mind like you
there is a very good chance that you are
doing better than you think you are
um
then uh I think that another like
implication here is that
like there's a tendency I think for
people to give excessive deference to
people who are particularly strong or
who have a particularly good physique
um like people just assume that like
yeah if this person is really strong and
jacked they must know what they're
talking about
um or if someone isn't as strong and
isn't as jacked as someone else like oh
like they either don't know what they're
talking about or they're just not
putting in the work
and like I do think that that is
probably
directionally true on some level like I
I think if you took the entire universe
of people who deadlift 800 pounds and
the entire universe of people who
deadlift 200 pounds Ah that's not a
great example the 400 pounds the the 800
pound deadlifters do probably know more
about deadlifting on average than the
400 pound deadlifters do generally just
because I mean they've been they've been
doing it longer if they they're probably
com they're probably competing if they
pull 800 pounds so they've probably
devoted more time and headspace into
thinking about it and whatnot so like
there is probably that rough correlation
but it's
not nearly as strong of a correlation as
I think a lot of people assume like
there are a lot of very very bright
lifters and coaches who just didn't have
the best genetic draw for for lifting
and they know what they're doing uh
they're they're good like they're they
know how to train themselves or if
they're coaches they know how to train
other people but like they're not gonna
squat 800 bench 500 whatever just
because they didn't pick the right
parents for it and that's totally fine
so don't uh immediately assume someone
either isn't training hard or don't know
what they're talking about just because
they're not freaky huge freaky jacked
super strong and conversely don't
automatically assume someone knows what
they're talking about because they are
super strong or super jacked like there
are there are plenty of people who just
picked tremendously good parents for
resistance training who who don't who
don't have any [ __ ] idea what they're
doing
um yeah they they just they just lucked
into a good situation uh
and then finally just just to recap like
if you are struggling with your results
some things that you could try to get
things moving in the right direction uh
one make sure you have your ducks in a
row outside the gym two just keep
training small gains do still add up
over time three uh if you have the the
motivation and capacity to do so in
general if you train more or train
harder that will tend to lead to better
results uh four measure more variables
like you know strength might be going
well even if you're not building a ton
of muscle or vice versa uh five
experiment with different training
Styles this does not conflict with
continuing to train you know you can
train more you can train harder you can
keep training but if none of that's
working just try training differently uh
there might be a different style of
training that you respond well to that
maybe does differ from the norms and
trust your own experiences there and
don't be afraid to experiment and
troubleshoot
um
and uh
finally like
embrace the other benefits of training
Beyond
purely physical capacity slash body
shape those those gains and health
markers longevity uh Mental Health Sleep
Etc like those are real tangible
benefits that you can see from training
even if you're not putting on all of the
muscle you want to like it is still
doing beneficial things for you and
you know if you feel like you're banging
your head against the wall and you're
not seeing the results you want and you
just don't like the training you're
doing there is absolutely nothing wrong
with just trying to find a different
overall style of training that you both
respond better to and that you just like
doing more that you that you find more
kind of intrinsic enjoyment and and
ultimately that's going to be much more
strongly predictive of whether you do it
for a long time and whether you know
whether you stick with it long enough to
see notable benefits both physically and
in terms of you know mental health
longevity uh all of that other good
stuff awesome yeah that is a ton of
really good information uh about
heterogeneity and responses to training
right so I think this has been a really
great episode because it helps people
understand how much variability is
normal you know when looking at how
people respond to different training uh
and then more practically speaking if I
suspect that I have kind of below
average responses to training what can I
actually do about that moving forward
right so I think it was a really
well-rounded episode I know a lot of
people uh in Trex Nation the Trex Army
is what they call themselves they're
going to be upset this is a very Greg
heavy show but
don't don't be upset don't be worried
I'm gonna be coming back next week with
a segment about mindfulness and how that
might have some applications within the
Fitness World so this uh this particular
episode very training heavy but
ultimately answering a lot of questions
that a lot of people have out there in
the world I have no idea how the [ __ ] I
thought I was going to get through that
in 45 minutes uh I don't know I if I had
to speculation that's one of my hardest
bag fumbles I of all time so I don't
want to be uncharitable with my
assumptions but when I went for like an
hour and a half on reverse dieting I
mentioned in the aftermath that I had
set the new record for delusion and
misunderstanding how long my segment
would be and when I go back and edit I
am going to tally things up part of me
feels like you were just trying to break
the record I I truly was not I I looked
at my outline and thought
yeah like I 30 minutes is gonna be
pushing it but I can round this out in
45. uh not at all I don't I don't have a
great a great grasp on how long things
take well the good thing about making
that exact same mistake is that I can
have empathy and truly understand like
yeah with the reverse dining I looked
back at the outline I was like why why
did I think that would take 20 minutes
yeah no there's no reason to believe it
I I just [ __ ] up yeah at least at
least I didn't get distracted by uh
pondering whether there were babies in
any of these samples of the studies I
talked about that's true
um is anyone gonna get that I think I
edited that out of the previous episode
yeah you did that's fine that's that's a
little one for us yeah okay
um so to put to prevent any other
detours or threats to our continuity in
the episode I'm gonna go ahead and cut
it uh as always thanks so much for
joining us and we will be back soon with
another another episode of The Stronger
by science podcast
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules we
hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
can sign up for the free newsletter at
strongerbuyscience.com newsletter or
just go to the stronger by science
homepage and click the free programs
button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our Facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]